I find my nails like a ninja
[Music]
yeah
Oh
what if I told you this is last Monday
morning in your life
[Music]
okay these around the corner once
they're set ready to go we're just gonna
pick up with you in your office again or
walk over having a job this video guys
made for me which is really good
ya know one of the biggest difference to
beat one of the biggest debates in
business answered in 90 seconds
but it's where videos are only 50
seconds cool I post it anyway wanted to
do another renovations in China well
then we can just go on the pure content
strategy which is like post the [ __ ] I
do think it's worth the upside okay
shall take slander in my classes of so
much time how's the episodes gonna be
from yesterday some good stuff
what's up
[Music]
as planned Clark said that's over here
you know pop over not unless we can with
them there they do want to share with
you the deck itself good look at that
okay then do that in here okay super
simple walk and be like where do the
three [ __ ] that are going to get it
to a and like why don't we make America
like give a [ __ ] about getting it to a
pressure why don't we like so one of the
things yeah one of the things I think
has always worked for me is it like into
me because TV is doing it right now I
love breaking the third wall like that's
when he gets real honestly
I've got another idea idea number two
and this is [ __ ] big
I'm telling you big guys honestly it's
really big though
yes you know this honestly this is the
one I want to do I'll [ __ ] them so into
this ready I think you should come out a
campaign that says [ __ ] for now wait out
the campaign
[Music]
you see by the waiters move on your box
about
if innocent I'm really conscious I'm
here for you does in this case one thing
that we that Restorick Lee we did not do
that I'm fully on board with is I want
to fight look I'm say now let them let
them change their mind I want to make
these calls like like I really want to
be involved in this year I want to get
my hand with my dirt year like I I want
to be involved real quick
I'm very comfortable with you guys
discussing this whoever wants to take it
I think I want to play the John Madden
role I want to do color commentary I
think it's important for somebody that's
so bought into me to realize how special
this organization is above and beyond me
here's my punch line if we believe in
something enough we'll build the
internal capability yeah cool I was in a
meeting with the team getting prepared
for this opportunity and Eric was
updating me on the conversation he had
with you and I just wanted clarity for
myself and for you so that we can get to
to the best place when we're talking
about breakthrough work and things of
that nature
right you know obviously I communicated
this when we were together but I wanted
to make just hear it from you know from
you on this one
you know obviously my full belief is
that the breakthrough work comes from
the cadence and the strategy of Facebook
video against those segmentations more
so than the creative of course the
creative is variable but I want to walk
in there with five to six different
videos per market so the net cost of one
video for Europe
you know UK Germany things of that
nature it's my belief and their way to
actually change your business from a
negative slide I believe is to take the
money that is normally allocated to a
TVC and to do that in a facebook video
environment and then having contextual
creative per those markets you are 100%
right and even worse I always believed
that what I didn't know until maybe
three years ago was oh [ __ ] the agency
partners aren't incentivized and
figuring these problems out they're just
trying to maximize profit
that's cool I think every company should
have have agencies and do marketing
internally so that interests are aligned
because I genuinely agree with what you
just said it's down to the people and if
the people that are sitting on the other
side of you are also publicly held
companies and aren't incentivized in
putting in the hours or the work to
guess the spec to innovate but they just
want to keep selling you the model that
makes their margin you're never going to
get to the work Thank You Dean the
cameras already that's what my life has
come to a desk Tyler from a lot of
[ __ ] pain does it daily hey tear up
hills
Tyler edits so this is one of my least
favorite things to do in my life right
now which is renewed daily be I never
historically over the last decade
watched any of my own content but
there's so much I already had two or
three things out that would have been
asked context that could have exposed a
client issue I hate this but I love it
because I see all the time so you know
what I think we should cut that Liz yeah
I do 100% of my day is based on romance
ends with Ryan right here and the 1825
okay I have a master of premiere throat
you know um title whatever you would
dump with the funny thing to do about
two quick reactions oh yeah oh and then
you say like I'm sure
I like the quick reactions over there so
these are pretty promising
yeah care about you like the chair
really like the bulging secret look at
that chair that one hair or the right of
course you get it you know hundreds of
[ __ ] air right shall we do it good
[Music]